August 18 1987 et was there when
Jennifer gray brought her father Joel to
the Dirty Dancing premiere in New York
Patrick Swayze posed with his buddy Eric
Robert I mean Jennifer and Patrick how
can you ever recapture that magic well a
TV remake is helping the time of your
life can happen twice
what's your name Hey do me a favor baby
they don't watermelon i son longhouses
Snapple
nobody puts Baby in a corner ever hard
to believe it's been nearly three
decades since the original well now
abigail breslin is baby
taking on the role made famous by
Jennifer Grey and newcomer Colt Kratz is
Johnny
the resort's dance instructor originally
played by the late Patrick Swayze who
just oozed a sex appeal you can't try to
be sexy you have to just go for the
reality of the character and make people
love and care about this human being
that you're portraying and then
sexuality comes out as a matter of
course if it's there and you may
recognize the new leading man and his
ABS from Pink's music video try now
rounding out the cast Sarah Hyland as
baby sister Debra Messing is their mom
Katie soval is Johnny's summertime fling
and that's J Lo's ex vote cats were
smart as his best friends
the three hour television event
recreates many of the iconic moments
from the original like the log scene and
all those lifts and it will include
updated versions of some memorable songs
like the time of my life back in 1987
Jennifer told us she had the time of her
life on set learning her moves I would
like people to start dancing like that
again I'd like that to become a way that
people go out in a date it's very like
old-fashioned and romantic and fun
romantical fashion all the good work
yeah well ABC's Dirty Dancing remake
well err maybe 24
[Music]